for reaction to today's vote and the
path ahead joining me now from Atlanta
ranking member of the House Judiciary
Committee Republican Doug Collins Thank
You congressman for being here your
thoughts on this day and what the
fallout is from it well as I was on a
flight back to Atlanta it was a really
sobering thought
because really what I had said earlier
today really began to hit and that is
that a dark cloud is falling upon the
house and it's not a cloud of something
that we have not known about it's
something that Democrats have talked
about now for well over two years or
almost 30 years since Donald Trump was
elected but what they did today was is
again went to the floor of the house and
shredded our procedures and shredded our
rules and lied to the American people
about saying that they wanted to be fair
how is it fair what they did today when
they're gonna continue their sham under
you know behind closed doors
push that possibly having a couple of
open hearings but having no input if
they're really in an inquiry having no
input from the administration or any
lawyers from the administration or
anyone else waiting till later to do
that in the district committee really
it's just a sad state of affairs and
they're gonna have to answer for that
one day you know there have been
Republicans behind these closed doors as
you know redirecting asking questions
following up we haven't seen the
transcripts of that but they've been in
the rooms now you're heading into this
public hearing timeframe aren't you
going to have a chance to in front of
the American people make the case by
redirecting the questioning on some of
those witnesses well we're gonna have
the chance Brad and I think this
interesting you talked about not seeing
those transcripts I'm a member of the
House I'm a duly elected member of the
House from the state of Georgia and our
rule book says that I could have access
to any of those transcript that I want
as long as I asked for those from the
relevant committee chairs I've tried to
do that that rule has not been replaced
it's not been set aside and yet they
will not let me as a member of the House
view those transcripts as we look
forward to this right now what they are
doing those Adam Schiff and other
members of that committee are leaking
out only the parts that they want to
leak out and threatening Republicans not
to leak out anything this is a one-sided
event this is what I mean by the fact
that the Democrats are simply shredding
the processes of our house because
they're not allowing the Menaul
having any possibility under normal
circumstances to view the very things
that they're working on the American
people deserve better than this if
you're going to overturn an election
then you ought to be a lot more
transparent about it here's what
Democrats are saying they're saying that
you all have been talking about process
you've been demanding a vote on the
inquiry of impeachment they did the vote
today they are moving forward with the
public hearings and they're calling your
bluff and now it's about the substance
do you have any problems with the
substance of what you've seen so far
oh very much so I mean if this is
calling our Bluff then maybe they didn't
hear what we were asking for we were
asking for the very same things that we
found if you're wanting to do it a
number at this to be very clear about
this if you want good process leads to
good substance unless you've already got
your mind made up on what you want Adam
Schiff obviously seems to have
impeachment on his mind then you don't
care about process but true process
makes you go and look at the facts make
a fairness process and then you
determine something we did this under
Clinton we did this under Nixon the day
they put out maybe eight pages of how
they want to handle this by the way we
still don't know how they're going to
try to take those transcripts and get
them to Judiciary Committee we don't
have a time frame we don't know how
they're gonna open that up we don't know
anything about when how we're actually
to be view those and how they get to it
when they get to our committee how the
president his team and how we'll be able
to have hearings there's no process in
there to say yes the Judiciary Committee
is actually gonna have an open hearing
are we gonna be simply remand to the
report that Adam Schiff gives us if we
are then Adam Schiff better be there to
testify the problem is is they want you
to appear that they've done something in
reality all they did was solidify Adams
just control they kicked og are they off
the Oversight Committee out they kick
Foreign Affairs out and tightened it
down even further for them to tell the
American people that this is something
good then I challenge him as I did on
the floor today let's have an honest
debate if you want this to be a true
inquiry then treat it with the respect
and the deference that it deserves not
the down the way that they're doing it
now in the basement of the Capitol
simply letting people know what they
want to know here is congressman Clyburn
and speaker Pelosi to tactical ISM the
heart of the conflict the more glorious
the triumph
we are here today because ray
dedicated public service and patrons or
standing up for their country nobody I
doubt anybody in this place or anybody
that you know comes to Congress to take
the oath of office comes to Congress to
impeach the President of the United
States unless his actions are
jeopardizing our honoring our oath of
office I understand
congressman your arguments about process
you're arguing arguments about fairness
they on the floor numerous times talked
about the substance of concerns of men
like Colonel vane men like other people
who have testified about this call and
what they saw behind the scenes on the
substance question do you have concerns
at all no not at this point and let me
just go back to what miss Pelosi said
right there she said that they didn't
come to Congress to impeach did we not
have a huge controversy the day of
swearing in from a congresswoman from
Michigan mr. Lieb who said this we're
here to impeach him I mean come on miss
Pelosi you know better than this you're
just pandering to the American people
when you say that but on the substance
issue
Brett I'll go to the substance issue we
can talk about process which we get this
out in the open and people to see but
let's talk about substance we see the
transcript we know what's in the
transcript we see what is there
we know from President Trump and
president Solinsky that neither have
said that there was any pressure
president Solinsky said there was
nothing from his side that calls him
concerned we also know for a fact that
the Ukrainian government did not even
know these discussions were going on
until late August at the earliest when
this call took place on July 25th we
also know that bill Taylor one of their
star witnesses was not on first-hand
information not even second and not even
a third hand he was on fourth hand
information so if we go forward in this
we're going to definitely hit the
process problems but we're also gonna
hit the substance because at this point
in time this everything has been laid
out has shown nothing that the President
did wrong just as exactly as what we did
for 10 months in the Judiciary Committee
while we were saying that he was
basically a Russian agent let's let the
people take a deep breath and see the
facts for what they are congressman Doug
Collins we appreciate your time
Brett's always good to be with you take
care